somebody told me god is simply what we
don't know
[Music]
i saw a butterfly it was dead but it was
gorgeous
and all the robots are just walking down
the sidewalk
kings that are little empires that they
made up
[Music]
and i'm one
yeah
wide open
[Music]
dusty got shot and the nosher got
married
stewie's still dead and commitment's
still scary
and i got a new woman but i treat her
like my old one
[Music]
if i keep this up i know i'll end
up with no
[Music]
one open
yeah i don't think anything matters
i don't really care at all
you want to start a revolution
but nobody cares everyone's tired work a
little bit harder
and baby soul will eye
you want a revolution
nobody cares everyone's tired
[Music]
and the promenade's filled with the gray
cloud it's dripping black all over the
playground and the museum's all filled
with the snapchat i got the head of a
dog in my backpack and underneath all my
clothes is a snakeskin that i stole from
the temple when it caved in cause they
built it too close to the fault line
when the capital burned we were all high
on the beautiful mess we created there's
a thought in my mind this is sacred in
the future this will all be ancient and
the water in the sink has been tainted
with the urine of the governor's
firstborn on his second birthday got a
surfboard but he crashed it ever since
he's been dirt poor so he picked up the
guitar he's trying to learn chords and
the people want to start it all over
cause the poets just murdered all the
soldiers and the monks have got on their
shoulders and the world's just another
day order
time wrote a new constitution
jimmy wants to start a revolution my
week is
wide open
[Music]
[Applause]
wide open
[Music]
open